les jours gras on y est dans
l'après-midi les carnavaliers
envahissent cette rouille notamment le
boulevard général de gaulle
des milliers de personnes qui dansent
sautent écrit la liesse comme à nulle
autre pareille
mais à côté les rues du quartier terres
sainville perpendiculaire les unes aux
autres et en levant les yeux les
appartements une période très difficile
pour les résidents même souffrait mais
tout part d'une main tout fait mais là
pour nous faire mes fenêtres pourquoi
temps puisque c'est le tout grâce à
nadia dix mille autres à monter à 300
sel va continuer d'épauler vadc du maton
par damian quoi comme ceux qu'on a fallu
bouger si porter ces quatre jours oblige
à tadjoura fini madame je fais comme je
peux
je suis souvent ouais je pars avec
ghislaine jeu mais quand des habitants
une graine donc je m'attends à une
vilaine vous voyez il est à peine disait
regardez vous entendez alors le centre
ville et les quartiers proches plus de
3000 habitants
si le carnaval fait partie de la
tradition soupape de sécurité pour
certains reste que le bruit ne fait pas
de bien le sens je bouge
je bouge pas ces derniers soient
ailleurs ou chez autre chose aussi où je
vais à la plage chaussures en bon je
rentre vraiment au petit matin
cuir juste le bruit voilà je suis obligé
de fermer les pièces les fenêtres et les
portes pour diminuer sur le bruit mais
des fois c'est vraiment gênant surtout
par rapport à la cloche qui vraiment
fort et le vide et des foires et surtout
il ya les jeunes à cuba jack qui s'amuse
ça peut se comprendre mes défauts se
penser aux habitants comme nous étions
opposés
j'habite ici mais je suis d'ici alors
j'ai toujours eu le goût du carnaval qui
tourne aux côtés le brouillard le oui ne
me gêne pas on s'habitue rui je ne sais
pas si c'est une question d'habitude
mais pendant le carnaval c'est il faut
lui oui
retour à une situation un peu plus
normale jeudi prochain